No,
I don't,
I don't believe in a class.
I,
uh,
you know,
I hate to always sound like a middle of
the road or I don't believe in a clash
of civilization.
I think the other thing that's a helpful
way to look at it,
and I think,
um,
I think Muslim people or a Muslim people
around the world are probably like
everybody else around the world.
And people are more or less the same.
They care about their children.
They care about the opportunities they
have.
They care about freedom and self
expression.
And when they feel,
uh,
you know,
whether or not their worldview is,
is right,
uh,
on this,
you know,
when they feel dictated to are
tyrannized,
even if it's the tyranny of a culture,
even if it's the tyranny of Mickey
Mouse,
you know,
invading their homes,
uh,
they,
you know,
they're,
they're going to stand in opposition.
And I think there's a sizable number of
Muslims,
and by no means a majority who,
uh,
you know,
who feel threatened by the,
by,
by America's place in the world and by
the export of American culture and the
militarization of their region.
And,
uh,
and I don't think that makes it a
civilization class.
Cause then that implies that it's a
battle to the death and you can never
win people over.
And I think we know that's not true.
And I think history tells us that's not
true.
Uh,
that,
you know,
people make decisions that are best for
them and best for their children and
their families and their economic
wellbeing and their safety.
Uh,
and if they,
and,
and if,
you know,
and they'll change their minds and their
worldviews according to that.
Um,
but do I think that it's all overblown?
And that in fact,
there is no,
uh,
you know,
army of radical Islam that in fact,
September 11th was just an isolated
incident.
And as somebody has,
one Democrat recently told me,
you know,
if you'd,
if you'd gone to sleep on September
10th,
2001 and woke up,
you know,
last week,
you'd think that we'd had 12 cities
destroy.
We've completely overreacted.
I don't agree with that.
I think,
I think it's a serious defining threat
for this moment.
I think there are people trying to kill
off.
I think there are many people trying to
kill us.
I don't think this is the red scare.
You know,
the John Birch Society and Bob Dylan
singing about looking under his toilet
for communism.
And I think this is,
I think this is a,
a and an and a relatively organized and
very dangerous group of people who,
who can and probably will get access to
the worst kind of weaponry we know.
And if we didn't,
if we didn't take that seriously as a
foreign policy priority,
I think we would not be doing,
you know,
we would not be fulfilling our
responsibility to the world.